the clock is no longer ticking  after four years of collective effort  and eu  unity to preserve peace and stability on  the island of ireland  to protect the citizens and the single  market  to build a new partnership with the uk  thank you all thank you all this is the  work of so many women and men  here in the commission under your  leadership madam the president  all the services and in particular the  eu  task force for the brexit with clara  martinez  and paulina deschmeck and other team  and in the member states the council  the european parliament  i also paid tribute also to the  eu uk negotiating team  and the chief negotiator david frost and  his deputies  this process has engaged so many  citizens  businesses stakeholders and  obviously so many journalists  thank you for your patience and for your  attention  today is a day of relief  but instant by some sadness  as we compare what came before  with what lies fed